Harvey Weinstein faces new and more
serious sexual assault charges involving
another accuser the Manhattan district
attorney announced an updated indictment
yesterday against the disgraced
Hollywood mogul it includes two counts
of predatory sexual assault and criminal
sexual act in the first degree
the charges stem from an alleged
encounter in 2006 in May a New York
grand jury indicted Weinstein for
alleged sex abuse involving two other
women
Jericka Duncan is here with the
expanding criminal case Jericka good
morning good morning the New York
District Attorney's Office charged
Harvey Weinstein with new felony counts
Monday to are for predatory sexual
assault the maximum sentence for that
offense is life imprisonment now the
DA's office says the additional charges
are linked to a woman who claims
Weinstein sexually assaulted her in 2006
Weinstein has already been indicted for
the alleged assault of two other women
in May you may recall a grand jury
indicted Weinstein on charges of rape in
the first and third degrees as well as
criminal sexual act in the first degree
Weinstein denies any wrongdoing in fact
in a statement Weinstein's attorney told
CBS News the 66 year old will plead not
guilty to the additional charges the
attorney went on to say Weinstein plans
to be fully vindicated and that it is
unjust to charge Weinstein as a predator
when the interactions were each
consensual we have learned that
Weinstein is also expected to be
arraigned on Monday in all more than 75
women claimed the disgraced movie mogul
assaulted them or acted inappropriately
again he denies any claims of
non-consensual sex Norah
all right tarika thank you